[Music]
in switching it up news submitted by
smoke detector beep literally the most
horrifying I hate that [ __ ] sound like a
good pretty loud using one hell of
piercing it's the absolute worst I
[Music]
thought you did that and you hurt your
own ear I thought we moved on so I was
like I really opened up my ears guard
was down so mad when that should happen
huge told it really like it happened
like three in the morning one time and I
got so [ __ ] mad threw a shoe at it
those things have like a backup to a
backup battery as [ __ ] to the beeping is
because the battery's dead oh yeah but I
just take the battery out and flew
across the rocks yeah yeah every time
and it still beats you exactly right
yeah
burn the whole condo down Netflix will
be releasing three films and theaters
before releasing them online that's
weird
they're funding theater films now that's
so expensive though innit that's kind of
Netflix stuff is already expensive well
they're early highly funded so they
didn't just put in theater to make more
money off of it than why not
do they just took out a loan for two
billion dollars to make new [ __ ] oh my
god I feel like they're just trying to
show their nuts at the world like
they're showing like Paramount Pictures
look at me [ __ ] I'm stepping
into your space that's tight as [ __ ] I'd
want to be on that [ __ ] what they
probably do need the budget though cuz
ya'll know netflix adaptations are like
absolute trash that's to talk about the
anime adaptation like the adaptations
and like I feel like a lot of the
originals too like stranger things seem
like strangers oh this is good good
there's a there's so dark girl this side
of the room has movies on Netflix so we
just want to kind of keep the
relationship to
support all of us we really think that
they do a great job me never having a
Netflix special let me tell you I love
Netflix subscription do you remember the
subscription when you could get like
five CDs to beat for three one or five
how I originally knew I loved that you
could email it to you and then the
postage was paid for so you just send
never burn it yeah it was all the
scratch DVDs and you try to play the
skips all the time all over the place
do you remember red box I think that's
how I think Netflix [ __ ] read by these
red box first red no red box gonna
happen around the same time and it's
like all the Netflix streaming [ __ ]
started and so I think that every single
time I went to red box it was a scratch
deep disc every [ __ ] time so I think
Netflix was just like spending a couple
R and going all the red boxes and they
were [ __ ] all these things and putting
them back I swear to God killed their
business yeah right office is still
around though man like over the places
who still haven't figure out what
Netflix is which is kind of weird that
they don't know how but they're still
red boxes and people that say that they
actually like the experience of like
leaving their home to go pick a movie to
go pick a movie yeah that's like the
people who go to they stop one
blockbuster that's open and the people
who like to go there and smell it and
[ __ ] on my dude okay I get it the
nostalgia [ __ ] it's a little weird
sometimes you think it smells the same
as the other blockbusters they had a
smell they had a smell exactly so that's
what I'm saying these people do to
remember that trip we used to do that
all the time we first started dating
there's this blockbuster I went to and
you could get snacks like it just it's
all like movie going experience yeah I
did it was like the but all the classic
movie snacks that were there right yeah
corn caramel popcorn gum candy all kinds
of [ __ ] well it's also like when you go
out to a red box for blockbuster to get
the movie you're
I now have to watch this I put time and
effort into it and know that you have to
watch it like 72 hours or some [ __ ] yeah
you're like she's like Jenny we gotta
watch this movie right now but like
doing anything else you can just like
turn it off and you know you can watch
it again it was like a family thing to
like you got your parents like I
wouldn't mind my dad or something he
would take us and we would get a video
that we all watched together I guess
that was kind of nice but you can't do
the same thing just trying TV interview
dude the blockbuster thing we did the
off-brand [ __ ]
right next to our neighborhood and [ __ ]
well the mom or pop ones yeah we'd go
there and then there's always that room
with all the poor like I didn't know
what was in there there's always like
men walking by that in their moms like
yeah used to sign that room nice - yep
yeah I just decide I have a [ __ ] out of
that room and I'll walk by and I would
always pretend to look at the videos
next to that room everyone knows exactly
what the [ __ ] you're like right by the
beach that's like at Fry's Electronics
used to have a whole dude section and I
used to walk into it and then then be
like Oh everybody knows that you're
doing this I don't know why you're there
you [ __ ] idiot oh yeah Fry's
Electronics yeah was it like like
magazine section or DVD one of DVDs
there's all like hardcore porn along
yeah yeah you guys have a Hollywood
video out here yeah our blockbuster to
Hollywood video right across from each
other did you guys ever go rent a series
so my parents watched like pretty much
like it like a soap opera
I think Asian so magic like Ozarks but
it was like all in Chinese okay we have
a Korean video store so they'll tell
each other about oh did you see this
series and when I go with my dad to go
watch it they come out with my two
plastic bags full of VHS is because
there's like 13 of those things that's
what my family did when 24 came out we
like went and got the whole [ __ ]
season and came out with something like
this I think this much they were
obsessed yeah we don't watch anything as
a family
yeah I did give it back to Ted hard I
didn't even know that was a thing I'm so
sure that's her thing like up you might
say girl having a sad life yeah am I
gonna steal her thunder my back I have
both my parents what about you so great
[Laughter]
rolling through and watching some link
different JK videos and then there was
one and it was like Tiffany's sad one
liners compilation and I was like one
liners like in like it was literally
just boom boom boom yeah just wait for
the TIFF burning people down compilation
bro you build me up so I know you're
[ __ ] the butcher oh no you tear
people you cut people home tip rips the
heart out and looks at it and then can
only take so much and then I fight back
like maybe the girl is all good
I didn't even know all right so Netflix
here so they're saying that they are
going to release three movies in the
theaters first and then a few days later
they're gonna release it on the platform
no date this is kind of weird don't they
know they killed movies like how it's
all it's almost like me going to my ex's
place they killed movie theaters like
they're there they're like murdering
they murdered this entire business and
then now they're like doing a drive-by
after and being like you know that's
like going when you're driving by your
ex ex's house and looking at how shitty
it is your new Lamborghini exactly which
movie you know the ending so it's called
the Roma bird box and a Ballad of Buster
Scruggs I don't want to watch any yeah
the Ballad of Buster's drugs is a new
movie from the Coen brothers see I like
that okay and it will have a limited
theatrical run on November 8th eight
days before it goes on Netflix hmm
Roma November 8 of this year yes the odd
thing about the reason why I feel like
people don't go to the movies as much
too once it goes to theaters she's gotta
wait a month and it's back in this I'm
online you know what everything is
like the theater experience ooh but what
happens is this it goes is that worth
watching in theaters yes that does
nothing really is there anymore yeah
there's like films that I you have to
see that like for example like I don't
know like good you know I feel like a
lot of those like 3d animated [ __ ] or
like something with a lot of like no
avatar avatar like avatar some [ __ ]
right yeah
se9 and then we have you're just losing
your funny that's all good sometimes you
get lonely so I want to kill yourself
even the stuff with crazy cinematography
like I'll be on a plane and you know
you're like it's movie time right yeah
they taught 13 hours and then for me I'm
like okay these ones I have to watch on
a bigger screen and there's only some
movies i watch on a smaller screen you
can resist yes I have to enjoy better in
an airplane than anything else cuz I'm
so locked into it there's no
distractions yeah
cuz that's the only thing you have yeah
I don't I don't do that it's like food
like I'm just like [ __ ] it if I'm hungry
and I need to survive I'll just eat it
anywhere it doesn't matter what the
screen looks like I can watch any movie
as well you know it doesn't you don't
get that like the visual so I guess for
me I don't get the same visual
satisfaction
you know like seen something like this
blah and the crazy sound and [ __ ]
like 30 speakers are you and IMAX please
it's like watching a Transformers movie
on your phone yeah it's 3d yeah I'm not
like transformers right like you already
know what that movie is gonna be about
is probably gonna be way better in
theaters and it is gonna be at home
robots fighting cut the Josh Duhamel in
the Marines that's every time I think
because it's the Transformers that one I
don't give a [ __ ] if I watch it at home
or in the yeah I feel like that way too
but I feel like if you are gonna watch
it just watch it in the theaters because
it's not gonna be a good movie watching
the theaters because there'll be a
better spirits because they literally
create the sound for a theater I'll
avoid it because of the sound
I am [ __ ] deaf out of I have what he
could is a bad movie yeah I just want to
see robots kicking each other's asses
the whole time then they keep cutting
the [ __ ] Marines like it needs a
storyline it's like nobody's more robots
fighting because like those movies - I
feel like when when people get their
hands on it they're like well I want to
make this different have a better story
like nobody [ __ ] cares dude have
people die get their legs chopped off
I want to see people explode I want to
see some dude come up and be like you
know what I'm not losing today he's like
yo not today bro I just want all the
catchphrases again and again and again
seven main characters you can kill them
off every ten minutes but like this just
keep it going what do you think of that
severus movie is the same [ __ ] thing
that's gonna kill every character every
year and they come that one's tight yeah
that [ __ ] that movie so ridiculous I
can't wait for for the Expendables ten
years from now when they're even older
where it's like even more visceral about
how old they are it's not that low just
comes out on a wheelchair just launches
the wheelchair over somebody's body I do
want to say like there's no way he lived
and then he gets up gets back in his own
wheelchair and imagine a thirty-foot
wheel chair versus a little two inch
wheelchair it's way more epic if the
will yeah imagine a wheelchairs like
[ __ ] 20 feet tall
it's so much more thick so true not like
this little big little tiny lift your on
your little phone yes sir I'm done with
the tiny little bit I know you think
it's cute damn cute guys cute though
[Music]